what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing our series on
injustice to origins which we're kind of
doing until you know the injustice game
comes out really or at least until we
finish all the origins for the the newer
characters we might even go back and do
origins for the existing characters I'm
not 100% sure yet we focus our attention
on firestorm now here's the deal as far
as I've been able to tell the firestorm
that we're going to see and injustice to
is Jason Rusch it's actually not Ronnie
Raymond now I could be wrong
and if I am it's no big no-no huge deal
we'll just go back and do Ronnie Raymond
origin - but Jason Rush is basically the
second iteration of firestorm now in
truth DC had a lot of time to work out
the kinks with the firestorm character
when it was Ronnie Raymond and Martin
Stein the idea was though that you know
going into like the lead up so like
Infinite Crisis you know the way into
the basically kind of doing the soft
reboot without the Infinite Crisis event
the idea was to get rid of Ronnie
Raymond and replaced him with somebody
new now traditional fans of firestorm
hated at people who are looking for
something new loved it the standard fare
when it comes to changing up characters
in comic books up but Jason Rush is
actually a pretty cool character I like
the way is his whole power and his thing
is done but I want to talk about
something called a firestorm matrix for
a second because this is something that
really seems to throw people off the
firestorm matrix is a pretty simple
thing it's just a just a different way
of saying the power of firestorm now the
idea is what can firestorm do what can
like Jason Rusch do so jason rusch has
the ability to basically manipulate the
atoms of objects and he has you know was
fiery power and all kind of stuff but he
can manipulate the the I guess the
atomic structure of objects but he's
limited to the atoms in that object so
say for example that jason rusch were to
pick up like a brick alright he could
rearrange the atoms of that brick to
make it anything else but he can't add
atoms to it so he can't like you know
disintegrate a teapot and then add the
atoms from that teapot to that brick it
doesn't work that way he can only just
manipulate the atoms in that work now he
can manipulate the atoms to form new
molecules that in turn will turn the
brick into like a tablecloth washcloth
or something along those lines you know
whatever is it he wants to do but he can
only work with the atoms in that brick
so if that's a pretty straightforward
explanation but his orange is actually
kind of cool here and the reason why is
because it initially picks up with him
working at a normal job but the issue is
that he shows up with a bruised eye with
one of his eyes swollen shut and what we
end up finding out here is that it was
really his dad who did it that his dad
was an abusive guy now of course Tim
returning home is a pre
daunting task just because of the fact
that he's got to go back to his dad and
tell him that his employer Stan will not
let him continue serving people so long
as his eyes damaged effectively meaning
that he's lost his job temporarily now
of course his father's response is to
lash out but the reason why his father
so angry at the world it's because of
the fact that his dad had an industrial
job by following an accident where he
basically lost his hand his father
became an abusive guy towards his wife
who left and then became abusive towards
Jason who was the only person left and
so because of that the envy you know
exchanged between the two is one of
anger and one of resentment largely
because of the fact that the disability
checks that his father gets is it really
enough to keep up with all the bills
that are coming due and so Jason having
a job was kind of essential but it's
basically you know DC sitting down and
showing this oh this kids coming from a
pretty tormented place now it's not like
the most violently abusive place ever
right but it is still pretty abusive and
so because of that what's being shown
here is Jason as a guy who's basically
struggling with the world now because of
the fact that he's effectively lost his
job and because of the fact that he's
good-natured at heart in the sense that
he still feels like he owes it to his
father to help him with the various
bills and so on that come due especially
after his mother abandoned the family
the result here is actually ends up
taking a courier job with a pretty
illicit guy named Stevie
now Stevie's pretty either pretty seedy
guy I mean that's really what's going on
here like this dude is shady as hell and
it's one of these things where it's like
here's a package you don't open the
package you don't look at the package
you don't do anything with it you pick
it up you drop it off at a destination
and you leave and that's the extent of
your involvement he's a basic no-frills
courier now the idea here is that should
this first you know mission so to speak
be successful till the intern provided
more work the problem with this is that
on his way to deliver the package
there's a massive explosion and there's
effectively a shootout at the drop-off
point and so the idea here is that those
who were selling basically got the
conflict with those who were buying
things was sort of getting cleaned out
now of course Jason himself was caught
in the crossfire today so himself was
watching individuals who were killed who
were caught in the crossfire and
ultimately he's basically bonded with
the firestorm matrix know the reason why
this happens is because of the fact that
following the removal of Ronnie Raymond
from the DC landscape the firestorm
matrix had basically become this source
of power so it was almost like some
extra dimensional source of energy or
something along those lines but it
basically was going around looking for a
new house and so it essentially
settled itself
on Jason Rusch now of course with him
and viewing the essence of the firestorm
matrix what is up happening here is DC
starts harkening back to the days of
Ronnie Raymond and the reason why I say
that is because of the fact that Ronnie
Raymond and Martin Stein operating
together as firestorm was essential the
reason being because of the fact that
the firestorm power was extreme and the
sons you know being able to transmute
matter being able to you know achieve
all kinds of crazy powers and things
like that
it was ideally too much power for one
person to handle and so what the
firestorm matrix was is basically doing
here is it's pairing people a lot with
the consciousness of Jason Rusch and one
of the first people that appears them up
with is just one of the guys who is
involved in the shootout now of course
this is DC kind of giving us the lay of
the land showing us what happens when
jason rusch is operating his firestorm
and what happens with the voice inside
his head when the consciousness from the
other person is taken now of course
again we're kind of shown two sides of
the coin here in the sense that Jason's
in control of his own body when he's
operating his firestorm but he can
relinquish control if he's able to
figure out how and this other guy can do
it the problem is that Jason doesn't
know how his powers worked he doesn't
know how the firestorm matrix functions
all he knows is that it's just there now
of course this results in this guy
basically getting his mind back and you
know essentially taking off and so it's
simply just Jason again and that's when
DC basically shows us the idea that you
really need two people it's almost like
the jaegers you know from Pacific Rim
yeah you can't do it with just one guy
you got to have two people piloting the
pilot in the air by the way how amazing
is the name danger I really really
wish I had thought of that name earlier
and I could use it for like a
Playstation handle or like an Xbox
handle imagine like a DJ called
danger like live at Electric Daisy
Carnival danger like it'd be the
coolest thing it'd be a it's an amazing
EDM handle or something like that but
anyway um so what is I'm happening here
is that Jason of course reports back to
Steve Ian so hey look man there was a
great big huge shootout there was an
incident the package has been destroyed
that kind of thing and of course we're
not really told what the contents of the
package is but what we are told is that
Steve Ian tends to basically beat the
hell out of Jason along with a few of
his guys and so again this really begins
to see the you know the continuation of
the story when Jason goes and ends up
you know we you'll confront Stephen of
course this is a skirmish between the
two of them knows who's deal but
Stevie's mind gets absorbed into Jason
now this is when we learn more about
how Jason views himself and the reason
why is because of the fact that Steve
he's not nearly as unintelligent as he
may seem where Stevie's guys start
shooting up a place or attacking Jason
to basically see you know the various
powers he has where you can put up
shields at block you know incoming
bullets and so on and so forth the full
extent of his abilities in terms of you
know what he's able to do at this
particular point in time but with
regards to Stevie himself his
interactions with Jason in Jason's mind
is basically manipulating him saying hey
look man like I've been sorting through
your memories and while you're
obliterating all these guys out here
while you're literally wiping them from
the face of existence with your insane
amount of power what I see in your
memories is an abusive father like I see
a man who has been tormenting you ever
since you were younger I see a man who
you know basically drove your mother to
leave you know I see an inherently
abusive guy says look man you've got so
many problems let me solve those for you
like you have so many issues let me be
the one who takes over you know and
those problems will get solved now the
other half of this is that Stevie's
basically beginning to a road so because
of the fact that they're conflicting
Dean's conflicting ideas they're not
really working in unison but also
because of the fact if Stevie's not
really ideal for harnessing the
firestorm matrix and so the longer that
Stevie stays out of the limelight the
longer he's forced inside the mind of
Jason Rusch the more his body begins to
break down on the atomic level in terms
of you know its consciousness more or
less going away now the end result of
this would simply be that if it went on
for you know if it continued going on
eventually you know Stevie's
consciousness would just cease to exist
he would basically just be a body with
no mind inside of him so it would just
be a shell of a human being but of
course you know as they continue to kind
of go back and forth and because of the
fact that Stevie keeps prodding you know
Jason about his father eventually Jason
just kind of lets it all out and then
since Stevie's mind back into his body
again the result is that in the process
with Jason learning about his ability
abilities he accidentally more or less
destroys the body of Stevie and because
of this because as you know his physical
body reflects the changes in his in his
mind ah he's essentially just kind of
reduced down like a puddle of blood and
flesh and nasty stuff but again as its
origin sort of begins to wrap up what is
I'm happening here is that what Jason
getting back home of course his father
continues to be abusive he more or less
intends to use his powers going forward
as a means to effectively escape his
brutal situation you know living in
Detroit with regards to his dad and the
life that he hates so much
and it's not the most significant origin
ever so the biggest origin ever there
was one other origin that we got and it
was in 52 of course that was the event
they came after Infinite Crisis and was
designed to both give us you know
origins for numerous superheroes as well
as focused on the small time guys
while the main superheroes had
essentially vanished but that's two
pages and so there's really not much we
can do with the two page origin it's
like if this happened not happened that
happened that happened and we're done in
so there's there's not a whole lot you
can do with that I mean it requires a
little more expansion and so on but
again from here it was really just you
know Jason coming into contact with the
Justice League for the first time you
know meeting with with you know Jon
Stewart you going against Martian
Manhunter and that kind of thing and so
again it was kind of a cool thing to see
but his order was one of these things it
was that was systematically fleshed out
over the course of some you know 20
issues and they were constantly adding
things to it but in terms of how Jason
Rusch became firestorm and what he can
do this is pretty much the long and
short of it that's the what we've seen
here is really all that we need in the
sense that he's a guy that is able to
possess the firestorm matrix you can
manipulate matter on the atomic scale he
can put off all kinds of fiery abilities
different things like that create
shields to protect himself I mean he's
able to do your standard fare of
individuals and DC Comics that have
these sort of psychokinetic powers in
addition to him being able to manipulate
matter on an atomic scale but if you
guys are new here to come as explained
unless you guys have the sub button to
become part of the rod Court you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you guys
later peace
[Music]